hallo herzlich willkommen und so salis
wenn ich heute möchte ich euch mein
neues präsentieren und so wie ich jetzt
hier gerade sitze erscheint immer
ziemlich einfach einfach so ein buch zu
präsentieren aber an dem buch saß ich
weg wie ich die letzten wochen und
monate letztes jahr im sommer habe ich
schon mit der produktion angefangen und
ich möchte euch heute einfach so ein
bisschen erzählen was dahinter steckt
und wie viel arbeit hinein investiert
haben und was euch in diesem buch alles
erwartet ob es euch denn überhaupt
interessiert oder eben nicht
ja bei uns ist glaube ich so wirklich
das ganz besondere dass wir das buch
immer komplett ohne verlag machen
es steht zwar auf herta verlag aber der
herder-verlag das ist genau eine person
das ist nämlich die simone und sie nimmt
mir im prinzip einfach so dass
organisatorische ab und die simone ist
ein weg wäre ich ganz ganz tolle frau
die wir auch gerne unterstützen und die
wir vor einigen jahren schon
kennengelernt haben
sie schreibt nämlich eigentlich
kinderbücher und sie hat dann einfach
für uns schon den kontakt gehabt zur
druckerei und zur papier bestellung also
musste ich mich unsere dinge nicht
kümmern und habe wirklich das komplette
buch einfach selbst gemacht aber
wirklich auch schon beim ersten gemacht
und auch bei den weiteren seine
buchproduktion ist nicht ganz so einfach
und man sieht auch finde ich an meinen
büchern so ein bisschen die entwicklung
das heißt das erste buch ist zwar schön
aber natürlich ist jetzt das neueste
buch für mich aktuell das schönste denn
ich habe natürlich auch an erfahrungen
gesammelt ich weiß mittlerweile gehe ich
schreibe ich weiß wie ich die fotos
haben will
und natürlich ist das ganze für mich
auch ein lernprozess gewesen
die bücher schreiben mein papa hat mir
neulich gesagt das wusste ich gar nicht
mehr dass ich als kind da war ich so ins
alter anscheinend schon gesagt habe dass
ich mal back und kochbücher schreiben
will
also war es anscheinend schon immer ein
traum von mir schon damals gesagt ich
habe dass ich mal groß bin schreibe ich
ein buch als ich fragte was da sagte sie
ein buch mit koch und back kritik
er passt sehr stabil sei das hat sie
gesagt
außerdem alle zutaten praxis optimal
heftig umstritten
warum schreibe ich überhaupt noch bücher
wenn ich einen youtube kanal auf youtube
kann ich natürlich alles was ich mache
ganz detailliert erklären ihr seht alles
anhand von videos und ich finde
videomaterial auch immer ganz gut denn
man hat einfach direkt vor dem auge man
sieht wie es gemacht wird und natürlich
können wir uns da unter den kommentaren
immer wieder austauschen bücher finde
ich aber trotzdem immer ganz wichtig
denn ich selbst habe auch gerne einfach
was in der hand und wenn ich nach
rezepten suche und mehr so denkt was
könnte ich heute den bakken schaue ich
natürlich auch in meiner app aber so wie
jetzt gestern zum beispiel habe ich auch
einfach in meinem tennis classics
geblättert und habe mir gedacht okay
dieses oder jenes buch rezept mache ich
dann eben nach
ich finde bücher das hat einfach was ist
was wertvoll ist und deswegen dieses
buch bei diesem buch habe ich mir
wirklich ganz ganz lange überlegt wie
mache ich denn überhaupt also wie soll
die aufmachen sein
überleg mir zuerst einmal was ist das
thema das thema ist für mich backen und
ich wollte jetzt nicht nur süßes backen
sondern eben auch herzhaftes backen
machen dh ich habe mir überlegt welche
rezepte kommen denn hier überhaupt rein
was könnt ihr euch interessieren
und am anfang war ich wirklich so an der
überlegung weil ich es auch aus vielen
fachbüchern verkenne dass man es einfach
nachts icard sortiert das heißt hefeteig
mürbeteig rührteig biscuit und hab dann
gedacht so jahr 770 rezepte weil doch so
schon mal ganz cool
aber die idee habe ich dann doch ganz
schnell wieder verworfen nicht also
eigentlich wollte ich ein nettes ist
dicker wird als alice classic soll ich
finde es schon
sie sind zweieinhalb kilo es gab die das
nicht sonst alles gutes workout mal das
sind knapp 400 seiten
ich finde es soll schon dünner werden ok
ich kann ja einfach manche habe ich auch
voll viel wirklich fachwissen die ganzen
grund teige grundrezepte das heißt es
brauche ich ja dann jetzt
dafür mache ich dann andere basics und
bisserl einfacher mann ist zwar recht
beliebte scope
ich glaube was ich keine ahnung habe
so frage ich dich eigentlich gesehen
jetzt hat sich gebunden und kann später
training ist und 20 wahrscheinliche
grund warum die zwischen wieder an
gewicht weil ich die karte nicht gibt
oder ob sie ist ganz schlecht sarah
rufen dann frage ich sehe frage ich eine
frau sarah strömen
sarah morath ich mir keine hilfen
könnten ja egal das ist einfach zu warm
guck mal ich hab zuerst überlegt das
buch so einzuteilen sieben tage 70
rezepte warum weil sie eben meine
lieblingszahl ist total 27 uhr grund
tage zu finden die eben auch so basic
sind dass sie jeder nachmacht also ich
mache so hefeteig rührteig samstagmittag
diskret und so aber ganz ehrlich wenn du
mal luft auf dem kuchen hast du guckst
du doch nicht auch heute könnte ich was
aus hefeteig machen kann andrea somit
heute was ja deswegen bin ja überlegen
ich glaube ich frage erst mal die
community hier warum nicht den bug an
bug source wenn ich besuch bekommen
unser ich auf eine party eingeladen
mag jede farbiger man noch vor die
zweite party besucht ich danke sie
selten
ok warum nicht
aber mit deinem backbuch mich ab jetzt
sollte jetzt sarah besucht party nicht
können
es geht immer schief bei mir okay ich
analysiere jetzt einfach so ein paar
leute wannsee das backen und warum sieht
man warum sie vielleicht nicht so oft
packen bei sarah ist es nicht und keine
zeit weil du viel fotos war hierbei die
ok aber das sind doch schon mal ist es
so viel kuchen bei dir das ist zu hause
aber guck mal das ist schon mal sarah
ich habe das jetzt analysiert und ich
kann jetzt daran sagen gut es nicht
können das können wir beheben
aber dies ist keine zeit dann muss die
rezepte machen die schnell gehen hier
also habe ich hier schon mal schnelle
rezepte ok und party heißt für viele
dass man praktisch für viele so schlecht
bürgern so für viele außer kraut feder
genau und besucher wenn du besuch
bekomme ich mache was schönes was hübsch
aussieht oder wenn es geht besucht zu
erkaufen superc oktober
jetzt war geht es um eine community denn
die haben auch immer gute ideen
ich bin jetzt gerade wieder dabei das
fakt doch weiterzumachen beziehungsweise
fertig zu machen das sind echt in den
endzügen und diese woche werde ich noch
alle texte fertig schreiben jetzt machen
wir noch ein paar fotos die gefehlt
haben was ich von euch gerne wissen
würde wäre zu recht anders geht alleine
kochen oder was herzhaftes hoffen wir
mal dass scheidung nicht so oft der
grund ist als ich werde zehn grad die
kommentare mancher zuschauer aus und
daran will ich auch schon was immer zu
einem bestimmten anlass gebacken wird
das heißt ich kann jetzt anhand der
antworten kategorien erschaffen und das
buch so ein bisschen strukturieren
wenn die äpfel anfangen zu vergangen
also rechteverwaltung war für mich dann
sondern
jetzt schreibe ich auch auf
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt meine kategorien gemacht
und so die ersten rezeptideen kann auch
sein dass sich die kategorien noch mal
um schmeißt aber jetzt fange ich im
prinzip anzupacken also ich werde mir
jetzt eine kleine große zutatenliste
machen
das heißt ich habe dann alle basics da
ich habe genug mehl oder zucker qualle
grundzutaten die ich eben sonst auch
immer verwendet nämlich immer wichtig
dass er die zutaten in jedem supermarkt
bekommt das ist mal zuerst und ich werde
auch eine kategorie machen die mit wenig
werkzeug aus kommt also wirklich mit
basics die man daheim hat löffel gabel
und so weiter weil ich einfach denke
wenn jemand backen will muss man nicht
unbedingt eine große bank ausstattung
haben erreichen auch die einfachsten
dinge
ich fange jetzt einfach an und das war
bei meinen anderen büchern bisher auch
immer so das heißt ich stelle mich in
die küche und während ich in der küche
stehe entwickeln sich einfach so die
ideen wenn ich dann voll so im bug
vielleicht kann es sein dass ich eine
woche lang durch backe und die nächste
woche gar nicht mehr backe weil ich
einfach gerade so ich sage nicht so die
muße hat ist also irgendwie so keine
motivation aber meistens war es immer so
dass ich wirklich so ein paar wochen am
stück einfach gebacken habe die mädels
fotografieren dann alles es wird immer
alles probiert und es kommen dann
einfach die rezepte ins buch die ich gut
findet also meist immer alle
und es muss ein solches unrecht 130 aber
es passt wobei ich sag immer ganz genau
auf messen noch 1,5 und dann kannst du
eigentlich schon in so ein kleines m w
40 gramm sahne machen weil es sind
wirklich schnelle rezepte geben wirklich
schnell
auch ohne den klassischen super frisch
[Musik]
ich dachte die schokolade ist schon
weich oder du bist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
als ich mache jetzt gerade vor ein paar
rezepte immer parallel wir machen uns
immer so ein tagesplan was nehmen wir
uns vor
meistens klappt auch manchmal schaffen
wir sogar ein rezept mehr
und dann mache ich schon die
vorbereitung für morgen zur bizkit
backen man dringend da kann man morgen
die aufwendige sache machen heute bis in
die einfachen und ja diese woche haben
wir so drei tage am stück buchproduktion
und donnerstag/freitag mache ich dann
wieder texte und so machen wir das immer
so bis zu wechseln und die mädels
bearbeiten dann so lang und ich schreibe
so lange und macht das buch so stück für
stück fertig
hier muss der kunde kann aber trotzdem
mit basics für back anfänger
[Musik]
ja und jetzt sitze ich da ein paar
monate später das buch ist nicht so
geworden wie ich wollte denn ich wollte
ja ein etwas kleineres hochlagen mit
wenigen übersichtlichen rezepten aber es
war dann einfach so in diesem bug
prozess drin
das ist so wie wenn ihr einfach mal das
auto startet oder ihr wollt einfach
nicht mehr aufhören zu fahren also sowas
wirklich bei der buchproduktion ich habe
dann auch keine zeit mehr für oskar
pastior schloss mich jetzt einfach kurz
in ruhe backen und kochen und ich wollte
nicht gestört werden also habe ich hier
hinten in der küche wirklich unendlich
viel gebacken und acht kategorien
gemacht das heißt ich habe jetzt hier
einfach die kategorien ich erzähle euch
kurz kreative trocken bis zum
herzklopfen
das heißt dass ein rezepte mit denen ihr
die schwiegermama beeindrucken könnt
oder eine geburtstagstorte zaubern
können oder einfach mal für eine taufe
für eine konfirmation für ramadan egal
für welchen anlass auch immer wenn ihr
eine besondere torte haben wollt dann
schaut er einfach in der kategorie
kreative torten das nächste kapitel ist
mehr so an menschen gerichtet wie sarah
zum beispiel die dann sagen sie wollen
was einfaches backen was leckeres mit
wenigen zutaten die man vielleicht sogar
zu hause hat also gerade sonntags also
wirklich ganz einfacher herzerwärmende
kuchen wie zum beispiel der apfel tat
oder käsekuchen badischer klopse dann
habe ich noch eine kategorie weil ich
mir oft gedacht habe so ok es gibt auch
menschen die vielleicht keine 26
zentimeter torte backen wollen
die möchten vielleicht eher was kleines
backen sowie cupcakes zum beispiel also
gibt's da das kapitel bunte
kleinigkeiten nach herzenslust und ihr
seht schon ich habe alles sowieso mit
dem herz gemacht das heißt jedes kapitel
ist wirklich sehr herzerwärmend das
nächste kapitel und ich glaube das
betrifft wirklich alle sind nämlich
kraut wieder für eure herzallerliebsten
kraut wieder bedeutet für mich nämlich
einen kuchen zu machen oder gebäck zu
machen womit man viele menschen satt
bekommt aber eben die auch gut aussehen
wenn ich nämlich auch an so eine
schulfeier denkt oder vereinsfeste
firmen feiern
da hat mir oft so ein kuchenbuffet jeder
bringt etwas mit aber das ganze sieht
schnell bisschen unappetitlich aus weil
man einfach auf eine große menge was
gebacken hat und in diesem buch habt ihr
eben das kapitel kraut wieder sind
schöne rezepte die hübsch aussehen und
eben auch schon an
und man braucht wirklich nur ganz wenig
zeit um trotzdem 30 menschen und damit
sagt zu bekommen dann gibt es noch das
kapitel was ich auch ganz gut finde herz
erfreulich schnelle rezepte das sind
rezepte die könnt ihr wirklich super
vorbereiten am tag vorher einfach mal
schnell abend so nach dem abendessen
oder kurz bevor die kinder ins bett
gehen oder wenn ihr morgen sagt heute
nachmittag bekomme ich besuch aber ich
habe nach der arbeit keine zeit also
mache ich es kurz vorher vor der arbeit
stellt sie den kühlschrank und habe dann
einfach schon mein gerechtfertigt ohne
dass ich eben zu viel aufwand habe das
kapitel herzlich einfach und simpel ist
für alle die vielleicht nicht so viel
back werkzeug haben das heißt auch wenn
ihr back anfänger seid vielleicht eine
springform habt oder ein bug ring oder
ein backblech könnt ihr euch an diese
rezepte trauen denn die gelingen auch
ohne großes werkzeug also da habe ich
wirklich ganz ganz arg darauf geachtet
dass ihr da fast kein werkzeug dafür
benötigt und euch so erstmal so ans
backen ran trauen können es gibt dann
natürlich auch noch eine kategorie weg
für alle die vielleicht keinen backofen
besitzen oder einfach mal der backofen
den backofen aus lassen wollen
und da habt ihr einfach kuchen und
torten die ihr mit hilfe des
kühlschranks zubereiten könnt weil ihr
sie eben nicht packen müssen und zu
guter letzt habe ich noch das kapitel
herzhaft gebackenes da sind nämlich
leckere herz auf der gerichte drin die
man eben einfach so mal mitnehmen kann
oder auch zwischendurch wenn man hunger
hat picknick macht oder auch auf eine
firmenfeier vereinsfest mitnehmen kann
und es eben nicht immer was süßes sein
muss ja und dann hab ich mir gedacht
habe ich diese ganzen rezepte gemacht
und es wurden einfach immer mehr immer
mehr und ich habe mir wirklich lange
überlegt streich rezepte aus nämlich sie
fürs nächste buch aber dann habe ich mir
gedacht wisst ihr ich habe das jetzt
gemacht für dieses buch und ich habe
auch den titel backen für jeden anlass
gewählt weil es wirklich rezepte sind
und es gibt keinen anlass für den er in
diesem buch kein rezept findet das buch
so an sich einfach ein schönes
komplettes vollendetes werk ist aber ich
würde sagen hier stimmt ab denn erwartet
alle auf dieses buch und ja ich bin mal
gespannt auf die abstimmung
und dann habe ich mir gedacht wenn ich
jetzt rezepte nach hause nehmen das buch
kürzer mache und leichter und dünner
mache passt irgendwie auch nicht also
ist es wirklich so dieser dicke große
wälzer mit fast 500 seiten geworden und
damit wirklich alles einwandfrei gelingt
und meine rezepte gelingt sicher sind
natürlich auch sehr detailliert auf das
heißt ihr habt immer eine
schritt-für-schritt-anleitung ihr habt
vorne drin eine kleine zutaten kunde und
vectra kunde weil ich einfach eure
kommentare unter meinen social media
kanälen einfach analysiert habe und ich
weiß mittlerweile wo viele fehlerquellen
liegen und versuchen natürlich die zu
beheben
dh ich habe in diesem buch die
einstellen werte für den backofen ganz
genau angegeben obere einschub unserer
einschub heißluft umluft habe das alles
erklärt weil wirklich ganz ganz oft
gesagt wird ich habe mich an genau das
rezept gehalten aber es hat nicht
funktioniert und dann frage ich
normativer nach und es ist dann
irgendwie doch an der backzeit an der
temperatur oder an dem ein stellwert am
ofen eben gelegen
und das soll euch eben nicht passieren
oder ich erkläre hier die einzelnen
mehlsorten wie ihr was ersetzen können
sahne stand mittel und ja das war mir
eigentlich schon ganz wichtig dass vorne
drin so ein bisschen die basics drin
sind an denen ihr wirklich ganz einfach
erkennen könnt wo eure fehler liegen und
natürlich auch ein paar tipps die ich
jetzt auch wieder die letzten jahre und
monate gesammelt habe denn jedes buch
muss ich sagen ist es so aktuell dass
ich mich einfach an der zeit die gerade
ist orientiere und sehe was passiert
gerade bei euch wo sind die fragen wo
sind die empfehlen den kompetenzen
vielleicht und die versuche ich dann
eben zu beheben ja vor einigen wochen
war das für mich irgendwie noch so
unheimlich weit weg dieses buch in der
hand zu halten denn nachdem ich die word
dokumente meine rezepte alle geschrieben
hab ich habe dir praktisch zubereitet
und gleichzeitig geschrieben habe ich
sie korrigiert meine freundin ihr sollte
hat sie korrigiert und lektor hat sie
korrigiert die mädels und jungs haben
sie hierdurch gelesen das heißt wenn man
alle fehlerquellen behoben alles
einheitlich gemacht überall wo ich
dachte okay vielleicht versteht da
jemand etwas nicht nochmal umformuliert
und jedes einzelne wort hier drin ist
wirklich von mir geschrieben
dieses buch verlegen
normales leben sowie 80 millionen
menschen
dann mach mir den finger nicht so
komisch war
keep calm and cake
[Gelächter]
ich weiß jetzt gleich was doch jetzt
machen das alles wieder sortieren oder
war das der staffel der korrigiert war
das ist gebunden um mein gott oh mein
gott oh alles um ihr wollt nur testen
oft gut in mathe kontrolliert du das
word-dokument ich schreibe hier ins pdf
die änderungen und hier guck ich wie es
gedruckt war
wir kontrollieren nämlich jetzt gerate
werde jetzt schon mal ein probedruck das
heißt wir haben die pdfs erstellt haben
sie korrigiert anm lektor hat sie
gelesen freunde hans gelesen beim
änderungen gemacht und jetzt haben wir
beim mini einfach so ein probedruck
bestellt das heißt damit wir einfach die
bilder anschauen können ob die bilder
alle passen
und jetzt gucken wir einfach noch mal
nach endgültigem fehlern
ich will gar nichts essen und am rad ja
und jetzt gucken wir hier grad
ich gucke nämlich immer dass die zutaten
immer richtig geschrieben sind das heißt
wenn ich jetzt handeln und die sind
gemahlen dann schreibe ich 65 gramm
mandeln in klammer gemahlen dass die
eigenschaft immer dahintersteckt oder
hier steht jetzt noch sagt von ein bis
zwei zitronen
das war halt nur wenn ich halt beim bei
der buchproduktion bin und dann schreibe
ich das immer alles so schnell mit und
überlegt vielleicht nicht wie ich es
formuliere und dann formuliert es aus
und so noch etwa der hälfte der rezepte
habe ich gemerkt okay ich sollte die
sachen vielleicht vereinheitlichen und
ich glaube ich jetzt habe ich so ein
system raus auch für die nächsten bücher
sarah da wird es einfacher da schreibe
ich direkt somit wie ich denke das ist
dann in das system passt okay ich mache
zutaten
murat kann schon bittet einen text
endlich schreibe er muss seinen text
schreiben zum buch ja und es macht immer
auf whatsapp denn bob ist sein büro sei
bis zum beruf und ich werde nicht
lektorieren ok muss ich sonst versteht
[Applaus]
ich kann nicht mehr lesen
aber sarah da müssen wir einmal noch so
komplett zum schluss endgültige finale
pdf da ist - einmal noch durch gucken
und dann geben wir es zum druck frei
angst davor dass jemand fehler findet
oder irgendwas kommt
wir haben mit bestem wissen und gewissen
korrigiert überarbeitet ok kann ich auch
mal deine brille haben dass ich schlag
aus
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
alter schwede wie kamst du ohne brille
aus zustimmen ich habe links gab ja aber
rechts
das habe ich jetzt gemerkt dass nur
rechts weil mein rechtes auge fühlt sich
so an als würde ich jetzt sheeran
hallo ich bin frau doktor ist ja bitte
warten sie noch kurz im wartezimmer ich
bin gleich für sie da ich bin
gynäkologie und urologie nächste patient
herr ostern bitte muratow ist schon
bitter was haben sie denn für
beschwerden ich lesen muss seinen
bericht
nix für die kamera
[Musik]
az baggerseen
das ist eine springform ich finde den
hier bist ich weiß nicht ich glaube ich
dass ich okay nicht vertraute ja wenn ja
und dann auch brown ist blödsinn würde
ich ihre kranken
du meinst das vestische okay man das was
du sagst ich wollte testen nicht so
langsam
guck mal
nein soll du machst das wunderschön
vielen dank
immerhin sehe ich dann an der wenig
schreiben muss damit keiner die gleichen
fehler machen warum einige höhere die
schokolade muss schmerzen dann könnte es
auch weg räumen
[Musik]
da steht jetzt stehen
und jetzt was man auch video einfach
jemand geben die werden die höchsten
risiko ich kann es nicht überhaupt damit
die qualität stimmt also muss ich es
über erst noch an seinen rechnung
und da müssen wir uns eigentlich gleich
platz machen für die anderen torten dass
der kühlschrank ist ausgeräumt werden
somit passt nichts mehr ein sollte jetzt
er in einfachen hütten einfache rezepte
in logik oder eben wenig werkzeug weil
eigentlich fast alle drei welches rezept
ich bin eigentlich schnelle rezepte
wertlose ich habe wirklich so
diese erdnussbutter regeln weil ich habe
keine ahnung
genau weil b kann ja auch sein die torte
muss eben die sechs stunden genau eben
wenig werkzeug kann genauso sein und ich
glaube das ist da das zeichnet sich
dadurch aus das ist wirklich schnell
gehen von minuten machte der ihnen bis
könnte sagen oh gott ich mache noch er
ja unterwegs nur so eine viertelstunde
okay dann haben nämlich 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11
doch gut oder hier haben wir in jedem in
ihrer kategorie ungefähr zehn also wir
nehmen jetzt das ein rezept rüber in
schnelle rezepte weil es eher auf die
schnelligkeit ankommen hören und jetzt
hab ich aber eine kategorie mehr
das heißt ich habe jetzt warte 10 98 12
34 führt nicht jetzt 18 10 gezählt am
bin laden rückwärts hier haben wir
bereits sehen aber ich könnte jetzt auch
nichts weglassen und mal ganz ehrlich
also damit könnt ihr alles packen
ja für jeden genau
so ein foto macher noch unter den
feierabend wenn du es machst du schon
garnicht schlag sein buch meine hand ok
weiß grad nicht mal ich weiß gerade
nicht mal wie viel ich schon gemacht
habe ich muss meine liste wieder
aktualisieren
die hatte ich kurz in gefahr
übrigens ein genialer tipp wenn ihr ganz
schnell was kalt haben wollte
gefrierfach gras
[Gelächter]
jetzt schreibe ich den typen net ins
buch 20 minuten kühlschrank oder 58
ersatz ist kaputt gemacht okay es war
ein bild hat
war nicht so dass ich hab was man halt
so und vegan und veganer sandwich machen
[Gelächter]
mutter erdnussbutter und haferflocken
abhängig von professionell hier
ok also perfekt fürs buch noch mal hoch
mal ein bisschen höher halten ja sehr
gut auch einmal hier gleich mein leben
also nicht dass es nicht schon acht
stück davon gegessen hatte
[Musik]
dann braucht mich jetzt nicht mehr geld
ich bin fertig danach und dann
vielleicht noch von oben und dann mache
ich so lange die auf der torte fertig
und die schokotorte und dann kann man
einfach zeit wechsel machen perfekt
ich gucke ob man noch was haben für
dunkle habe ich mich nicht auf die
aktuelle grünen oder draußen
also mit den männern muss ich jetzt hier
auch einiges besprechen und zwar der
partie ist für die papier bestellung
zuständig vielmehr muss mir sagen also
du musst sagen wie viel weil ich kann
dir nicht sagen wie viele seiten
ich muss wir sehen wie viele seiten
dessen damit ich dann ist bier bestellen
kann
aktuell haben wir für 300 350 300 350
seiten das papier bestellt und wie
schnell muss wissen wenn ich noch 100
seiten draufpacken am besten vor gericht
muss sich deshalb schnell sein weil die
papier lieferung geht blogger vier bis
sechs wochen
es werden 100 seiten vielleicht auch 120
stellen doch nicht mehr weil wenn ich
komme jetzt überlegt man wenn ich wenn
wir jetzt mehr bestellt dann haben wir
mehr auf lager und ich meine was für
dieses buch nicht brauchen nach dem
asphalt fürst next dann bestellt noch
bei 350 450 seiten mehr weil die 300 450
ja ok und der chemie da ist es gerade
schon dran
da hab ich schon die ersten änderungen
gemacht und zwar machen wir jetzt diese
umrechnung funktion in der app der stoff
viel cola oder weil da kann doch jeder
mit jedem buch muss ja nicht mal mein
buch sein also jeder der im rezeptbuch
hat kein rezept dann umrechnen europa
fungieren irgendwelcher kochrezepte kam
er schnell um reichen und so vier
personen auf 6 ich meine dass krieg noch
jeder hin erweitert von 20 auf 26 oder
von 30 auf 120 darunter
da muss man ja die umrechnung tabelle
hatten wir schon immer und jetzt haben
wir sie auch in der alpha würden sie in
digitaler form bekommen und die wird
dann hier und man reinmachen
und dann kann man
die im suff verwendete waffe ausbilden
ob jetzt untergeht durchmesser 41 ihr
späteres leben kam also 61 ansehen okay
wer künftig regiert und nicht gewesen
studienbereichen will ich sehen stellen
backofen ist okay und jetzt soll auch
eine 20 aber ich kann es doch auch eckig
gelockt
das heißt ich kann auch einen runden
kuchen runden käsekuchen auch ein
eckiges blech macht man halt mal auf 20
und dann kannst du hier geben du hast
jetzt früher zum beispiel kann es noch
einfällt hinzufügen eintippen
du kannst die kuh weg bringen kann ich
die kuchen gleich weg bringen
weil ich den kürzeren metern er braucht
ich habe hier im sli kühlschrank habe
ich koche tun indem und drüben bei uns
und oben mal jung die jungs wollen nicht
mehr für alle es wollen nicht mehr
rechnen
und dann kommt auch 1806 fall kohl und
für die zukunft besser dennoch gehen er
wenn man sich das so abspeichern könnt
ja zunächst gedanken die notiz zu gehör
okay das so laut dass wird fertig bis
das buch fertig gedruckt wird den abriss
gebäude und vier bis sechs wochen
also nicht vergessen immer die updates
zu machen
auch die neuen funktionen bekommt ja
ganz ganz wichtig ok also wenn wir neue
funktionen in der f haben müsst ihr
immer wieder die abdeckung sowie die
neueste version ok perfekt gut sie mir
ich schick dir später noch videos weil
ich mach draht zu manchen rezepten so
handyvideos man muss man die mine qr
code ich mache weiter
ich schicke euch was hoch
wie versprochen ich würde mich bei dir
melden oder und zwar wir haben jetzt
entschlossen das buch etwas
umfangreicher zu machen
die sally hätte gerne 120 seiten mehr so
etwas mache für 200 seiten mehr
ich kenne die sally dass die 120 seiten
wenigen leben reichen
alles klar sagt sie mir bescheid ich
danke dir ist so etwas geben
wir mussten unser papier dann noch mal
nachbestellen weil eben wie gesagt das
buch 200 seiten dicker wurde als auch an
wenn ich mir das da überlegt zwei
mahlzeiten ist eigentlich also ein
komplettes buch hier reingepackt aber
wie gesagt ich konnte einfach es nicht
über mein herz bringen was zu kürzen und
parallel dazu hat er mag sich nämlich
schon an der die funktionen gemacht und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier nicht wie beim
classic soll heißen das etikett
lesezeichen kein lesezeichen drin da war
dem rechnungs tabelle immer drauf wir
haben jetzt nämlich mit musik zusammen
überlegt können wir denn so eine
funktion mit dem umrechnen der rezepte
nicht einfach auf die app machen dh ihr
habt ja bisher immer meine bücher meine
app gehabt um eine rezepte und konnte
dann mit hilfe der umrechnung tabelle
zum beispiel eine torte nehmen von 26 cm
auf 20 umrechnen damit einfach die
proportionen stimmen mittlerweile
brauchte die umrechnung tabelle nicht
mehr
denn viele haben auch das mit der
umrechnung ctio nicht ganz verstanden
wir haben jetzt noch einfacher gemacht
und haben die app entwickelt und ihr
könnt jetzt im prinzip einfach jedes
beliebige rezept nehmen ob es in diesem
buch ist oder in anderen büchern und
könnt hier in der app hier unten auf
umrechnungskurs ion gehen könnten teure
zutaten eintippen die gewählte backform
aus dem buch oder aus anderen rezepten
und dann eure wunsch backformen und dann
wird alles einfach umgerechnet und ihr
müsst euch wirklich nichts mehr
überlegen
also das ist wirklich ganz cool und das
haben wir alles kostenlos für euch
gemacht das heißt die ganze
entwicklungsarbeit dahinter steckt dass
sie am markt er sich immer alles gut
überlegen muss alles so einfach zu
gestalten dass es eben auch jeder
versteht dass es jeder nutzen kann
und das haben wir in diesem buch und in
diesem buch haben wir auch zum ersten
mal videos integriert das heißt ihr
könnt mit eurem smartphone einfach die
rezepte
denen eine kuh abgebildet ist abscannen
und da habe ich dann eine kleine
videobotschaft für euch also während der
buchproduktion habe ich zwar dennoch
nicht gerufen weil ich so stress sie im
stress war aber ich hab dann gedacht
kaum das probieren nehmen wir jetzt mit
auf video auf oder einen besonderen
schritt oder was man vielleicht beachten
muss und so habt ihr so ein bisschen
backstage einblicke in die
buchproduktion und ich glaube das macht
das buch auch einzigartig ja da können
wir nämlich auch im austausch stehen
kann mir kein händchen halten
wir machen druck und ich zeige euch
darum die wehr
manche sie wissen dass ich gucke ich
weiß hat wenn wir zeigen jetzt da kampf
zeigen und sagen klar
[Musik]
man riecht dann immer sogleich hab ich
kenne dich kennen geruch von meiner
ausbildung noch geschafft gemacht da
sind sie schon die ersten bilden sich
nun und discover muss doch irgendwie
auch erkennst du genau und da ist auch
schon wegen trüber und drüber das ist so
wie jetzt am ende ist weil wir haben
hier diese partielle lackierung genau
einmal die natalie und der murat kann
ich was ein bisschen zum buch erzählen
dass ich voll schön weiß sie schon
überall diese paletten und die bögen und
im prinzip nichts so fein das immer so
eine palette ist dann sind nur eine
seite also so genau wie es mehrere
sachen mehrere seien aber nur die sache
genau acht seiten drauf oder eigentlich
mal achtseitige wirklich 16 seite so das
heißt wenn man es mal ausreichend fast
500 seiten geteilt durch 16 ja müssten
hier wie viele paletten stehen einnahmen
ich bin raus viele partys
ich bin ich so gut war so was
500 geteilt durch 16 31 paletten 31
paletten aber nur weil wir jetzt keine
5000 ddp nach dem drucken und damen in
die wechselzone ungelogen vielleicht 80
und 90 kollegen
[Musik]
oder zitronenkuchen
da ist so lecker so wie sie zum beispiel
hier hast du 32 proben auf eine falle
es muss einfach ausreichend und 32 bei
16 er weist ungefähr ideen für bücher
hier drin versteckt und des dort okay
ich weiß das ist das schwarze roben
dann kommt der plaut der blaudruck dann
kommt der rote tropfen der gelder darauf
es gibt nur vier farben übereinander je
nachdem zwischen einander progressivität
diese karte also dicken bis die farben
der lebenssaft daheim aufgehoben da half
auch es gibt vier fahrer der drucker
daheim der tus im vier schicht machen
sondern drückt gleichzeitig genau und
wie hast du vier paar vier farben und
hast schon sonderberg oder zwei solcher
werke wo dann der druck kommt und eine
sonderfarbe das hast du ja auch mit
einem logo ein lokal der sonderfarbe das
heißt hier sind jetzt acht druckwerke
[Musik]
das habe ich das habe ich alles genau so
gelernt wie jedes mal noch können wir
mal vor der mahler war dusche
eigentliche star oder ja eigentlich
nicht obwohl ein foto machen bundes 20
liegen aber motor warm oder komplimente
jasid hören und wie es bei mir schon
ungefähr 15 jahre her wo ich es gelernt
habe und da war doch damals doch richtig
modern opel astra frequenz modelliert
und anderen drachten moran einfach da
hier fühle dass ich wohl ist so ein
bisschen zurückhaltend sein können
ja keiner was schaffen
euro
[Musik]
da steht die natalie internet ist aber
ich hab gerade noch mit dem auto droht
jetzt auch ein hallo mädels haben für
euch dabei
was macht ihr gerade schön
ja
nach der farbe kongo genau die musik
ganz kurz ich habe auch darüber gelernt
wie weiß nicht ob es heute schon gesagt
habe ich muss euch und zwar guck mir
darüber ob die punkte alle übereinander
liegen meist bei ansonsten ist es so ein
wilder und ich muss mal gucken da gibt
es ein raster kreuz richtig genau und
dann siehst du ob die farben
übereinander liegen
du weißt dann fiel ich bin ja wahnsinn
oder ich geh mal rüber und gucke was die
kollegen macht der monat ist
wurde aus
man sagt die expertin
[Musik]
das wird zum beispiel da oben gerade
eingestellt
farben
[Musik]
so habe ich dir schon mal erzählt dass
ich eigentlich bin ich habe es gelernt
wirklich das ist jeder buchbinder und
zwischen buchbinder und truppe gab es
immer stress weil im video hat der
buchbinder verschnitte jetzt immer
locker fehler machen wir machen keine
fehler ist übrigens die buchbinder also
wenn ihr was lernen kann gar nicht sagen
ja ich bin schon so lange da also
wichtige haben immer schon stimmen hört
nicht auf ihn erlebt ich gebe habe ich
schon erzählt dass ich darüber bin jetzt
ohne witze drüber während gehört ist
auch drucker leben könnte oder nicht
der spruch bin doch ich hier weihnachten
muss irgend jemand sein dem ich erzählen
kann was ich bin
achim bleiben hallo ich bin der moral
bin ich bin gelernter drucker du bist
auch drüber
zwar ist noch winter hier hat es gelernt
das was ich druck macht er machte ihr
kaputt gebinde erste aufgabe war schon
krass wie lang schon
[Musik]
aber auch alles immer alles hier gemacht
ich suche mal lachen druck
[Musik]
ich bin es auch gelernt darüber gehabt
das lernen und zwar auch grad an
artikeln der druckformherstellung das
können nur noch ganz ganz wenige
menschen wahrscheinlich eher und ich
sind die einzigen auf der welt der hilfe
auf diese maschine bedienen kann habe
ich hey bist du drucker oder buchbinder
feierlich fotobuch vom hersteller genau
dort ist die schwarze kunst macht mir
den fotos 2 weil wir sind wahrscheinlich
einzigen auf der weltkriege überhaupt
noch existieren ja ein paar gibt gibt's
aber die könnten wir zwei
[Musik]
das ist die heidelberger zylinder an der
maschine aber eben doch gelernt es ist
so knöpfe und brücken machen dessen
richtig alte maschine aber jede gute
druckerei hat doch diese maschine im
haus also eine pro bereit diese maschine
nicht hat kann nix so
[Musik]
oder ist schon mal ein
da ich noch habe ich mir schon erzählt
dass ich darüber bin ja wirklich
wahrscheinlich 72 und olympische spiele
der drucker war ich platz eins
goldmedaille
was mich drüber ein fußmarsch diese
loben da muss ich darüber nämlich auf
die kamera auch gut aussehen legen
filter darüber macht sich keine sorgen
über präsentiert die bösen kontrolliert
und nach kommen die bögen druckfrisch
aus
ja warum weil so wird es hier endlich
mal fachkompetenz
ich weiß nicht ob das die drucker bin
habe ich zeigen was ganz cool ist
warum wir in der zeiten in der zeit von
digitalisierung noch bücher drucken
ich bin selber drüber ich habe es
gelernt die weisung erwähnt habe es ist
einfach ein genialer beruf und wir
lassen das alles hier in heidelberg
gruppen die ganz alle unsere bücher wir
haben jetzt schon das sechste buch das
ist jetzt ein vorgänger displays das hat
250 sein dass neue hat 500 seiten
und ich finde es einfach toll etwas in
der hand zu haben es sei etwas ganz ganz
fertig ist der beruf des druckers ist
was geniales das papier kommt auch aus
nachhaltiger forstwirtschaft auch aus
deutschland und ich liebte es einfach
wie gesagt etwas in der hand zu halten
darin zu blättern und dass sich das
kleid über - auf dem display sieht und
und übers weite einen daran dass viele
von euch haben wahrscheinlich für zu
hause die in den regalen vielleicht nur
sauer aber es ist einfach etwas in der
hand zu haben etwas fertiges und
deswegen machen wird es deswegen machen
wir es in deutschland
das ist vielleicht ein paar cent teurer
aber es ist auch für den beruf des
druckers genial für die arbeitsplätze
hier in deutschland und ich liebe es
einfach und lernt den beruf des druckers
mal kennen ist etwas geniales buchbinder
können die aufwerten
wenn ihr wollt wenn nichts anderes zu
tun habe aber drucker ist würde ich das
genial was es gibt
[Musik]
das heißt jetzt hier alle druckbögen
fertig und dann kommt es zum buchbinder
den drei wochen plötzlich
juhu ich freue mich wieso unsere
gespannt auf für die seiten sind und es
kaum auf und jetzt muss alles noch
zusammengefügt werden
[Musik]
ich muss doch irgendwo noch immer 23 wir
sehen ja ganz fern das gibt's doch nicht
lauter buchbindern hier muss noch
darüber geben das gibt es doch nicht
[Musik]
hallo beschuldigung haben wir brauchen
durchhaltevermögen habe ich schon
erzählt dass drucker winken 25 mario
maus damen wurden in denen das ungleich
[Musik]
das gesicht gehauen aber bei coach meint
dass tobias elis classics das waren ja
schon
dallas gewann 2 24 24 weiß nicht 26 28
28 2,8 auf mein gott das ist doch keine
kalorienbombe ja aber man kann ja
einfach das mit zum workout nehmen und
dann schieße gericht eben auch weg
guckt euch das an wisst ihr das ist
gerade vis-a-vis seiner geburtstagsrede
mono solange das kind in sich und es
wächst und gedeiht ja ihr zwei männer
könnte es vielleicht nicht verstehen
aber ich habe monatelang an diesem buch
gearbeitet
ja da schon einmal gehabt ja das ist mir
glaube ich ja so ja wahrscheinlich
und dann kommt einfach am ende dieses
baby und ich habe jetzt so während der
druckerei phase hatte ich das irgendwie
so aus dem kopf verloren sagt komm
schnell kommt und jetzt kommt einfach
das buch und wir sind einfach glücklich
[Musik]
ich habe eine haftpflichtversicherung
wie es ist kann es ausgerechnet die
samira krank und einen im urlaub tja
pech gehabt mädels sind freuen wir uns
jetzt alleine
wir stoßen jetzt champagner das sorge
für bücher schlägst du jetzt heute damit
meint auch ob gott welch überlegt wir
haben das cover haben wir ja zweimal
geshootet
das erste was so schön erlässt weil es
das war ja aber das erste wort ist blau
war schön aber moral hat dieses bild
hier nicht gefallen
und da haben wir nochmal gemacht aber
ich finde es zwar auch wunderschön also
ich hab mich nicht entscheiden so schön
mit den qr codes
jetzt müssen andere entscheiden ja ab
heute wenn das video online geht gibt es
dann auch das buch das du das sagst ich
sag mal was mach ich das kann auch fall
mit einer unserer mira die 2
das war auch lecker coconut vlan ich
wusste bis dahin gar nicht was im kuko
moslem ist und dann habe ich einen
bekannten theorie gefragt fast sein
lieblings koreanisch und es gesagt habe
ich im kopf und zu langen macht und das
von leckeren jetzt habe ich in den
kocher nach plan
voll cool also sich jetzt alle
allererste buch und verlor es an euch ja
dann feiert der name reinschreiben das
schreibe ich viel freude mit diesem buch
deines celle schnurrbart ist schockiert
[Musik]
da ist es nun dicke wälzer mit wirklich
ganz vielen rezepten vielen basics
vielen kategorien und natürlich auch
wunderschönen bildern die wir auswählen
mussten leider denn alle bilder konnten
wir nicht nehmen
ich glaube insgesamt haben wir über 8000
bilder gemacht und die dann ausgewählt
bearbeitet und dann eben hier eingepackt
und wie gesagt ihr habt fast 500 seiten
wenn ich jetzt mal so vergleiche
denn ich denke für viele also der preis
das sind 44 90 also knapp 45 euro 45
euro ist nicht wenig geld aber ich muss
dazu sagen hier bekommt ihr fast 500
seiten fachwissen plus die ganzen bilder
die anleitungen und wenn ich es mal so
vergleiche mit samira schulheften ich
bräuchte 15 hefte unbeschrieben mit 32
seiten ungefähr und die kosten dann je
nach dem welcher hersteller und welche
herkunft etwa zwischen 22 und 25 euro
für ein ungeschriebenes heft was einfach
immer wieder nur nach gedruckt wird mit
miniatur oder kariert und hier habt ihr
einfach ganz viel wissen drin viele
anleitungen und viele rezepte und
einfach monatelange harte arbeit
gedruckt auf deutschen papier aus der
region gedruckt in einer deutschen
druckerei wir achten da wirklich auch
drauf alles was hier drinnen steckt ist
hier im haus gemacht worden
das heißt alle bilder alle fotos alle
texte alles von uns gesetzt und dann
kurz einfach hier in der region in
heidelberg bei unserem freund vinnie
gedruckt also dachten wir wirklich auch
schon drauf so was nicht im ausland zu
machen weil es eben ein paar euro
günstiger ist sondern die region mit zu
unterstützen und gerade die druckbranche
muss man sagen ist eine branche von der
viele sagen die einfach ausstirbt
was nicht passiert wenn wir weiterhin
bücher schreiben und wenn menschen auch
nicht zu ebooks greifen
ich muss auch sagen dieses buch keines
meiner bücher gibt es als e-book weil
ich einfach findet dass da der wert des
buches verloren geht
ich habe auch selbst und nicht books
gelesen vielleicht mache ich es
irgendwann mal ich will dass also ich
will jetzt gar keinen schlechtreden der
sowas macht aber ich für mich und für
meine bücher haben entschieden dass es
die bücher eben in gedruckter version
gibt weil ich es einfach weniger finde
und weil ich finde dass ich die drucker
branche ein bisschen unterstützen muss
und vor allem ihr wisst ja ich weiß
jetzt schon wissen
moralis drucker und dass murat legt dann
natürlich auch ganz besonders wert
darauf und der hat ja auch ein ganz
anderes feeling für das buch ich meine
ich sehe im buch und habe damals das
papier ausgewählt weil ich gesagt hat
eine tolle optik passt gut zu meinen
rezepten der buch hat er hat da
natürlich so dieses ganze
hintergrundwissen was ich jetzt in der
druckbranche nicht habe und ihn freut es
natürlich dann auch umso mehr wenn wir
das so machen zumal ich mich schon auf
euch freude auf die nächste stunde oder
auf die shoperöffnung denn da gibt es
das buch ja dann auch
und dann bekommt ihr ein stück weit
sally mit euch mit nach hause ich hoffe
euch gefällt dieses buch wie gesagt 1
habe ich schon unterschrieben und das
könnt ihr gewinnen
ihr dürft gerne einfach in die
kommentare schreiben passend zum anlass
backend für jeden anlass könnt ihr mehr
schreiben wenn ihr das buch gewinnen
würde
zu welchem anlass und für wen würdet ihr
denn was backen und ich hoffe euch
gefällt das buch ich hoffe es ist schön
strukturiert und meine überlegungen
kommen hoffentlich auch ganz gut bei
euch an
ich setze mich dann dem nächsten wieder
an das nächste buch da würde ich gerne
ein kochbuch machen
gerne könnt ihr mir aufschreiben was ihr
euch dafür wünscht was ich da machen
soll was ich machen soll
und ja dann vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und vielen dank an alle die mich
unterstützt haben auch während der
buchproduktion ich war ehrlich gesagt
ganz froh dass ich irgendwann nichts
mehr schreiben musste denn ist es doch
sehr anstrengend vor allem für den kopf
dann aber ich hatte immer so einen guten
ausgleich zwischen backen küche und
schreiben und das ist dann eigentlich
immer so das schönste wenn ich das tun
kann was mir gerade im moment spaß macht
und freude bereitet aber natürlich
steckt auch sehr viel arbeit dahinter
also bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]